X equals 2.
Like I mentioned before
this one is complicated and
I wouldn't be surprised if it took
you several tries to get it but
this is a great problem to practice on.
All right, let's start by
writing this as 24 x plus -2
times (x+3)026=12.
That will help us keep
track of this negative
sign when we distribute
the 2 to the x and to the 3.
All right, after distributing and
simplifying just a bit,
we get 24x+(-2x+-6)-26=12.
I'm going to remove the parenthesis and
combine like terms, so
to combine like terms I've written
the like terms next to each other,
and 24 x minus 2x becomes 22x, and
-6 minus 26 becomes -32, so, 22x-32 =12.
Now let's get rid of this 32
by adding 32 to both sides.
And we get 22x + 0 = 12 + 32.
And then we get 22x = 44.
We'll divide both sides by 22.
And x equals 44 over 22 which equals 2.